So the answer to this question is that
exons are considered part of protein coding DNA because
exons are eventually turned into protein. And the
same is true for translated sequence between start and
stop codons. They're all part of protein coding
DNA because the sequences that make up that DNA
are eventually turned into protein. And these other
reasons like introns, which are spliced out of MRNAs,
promoter regions which are responsible for initiating
transcription, and untranslated sequences, that are transcribed
in part of the MRNA, but outside of the start and stop codons are all
considered part on non-coding DNA. So hopefully
if you truly understand the concepts of coding.
DNA versus noncoding DNA. You will understand
why each of these types of DNA sequence
would be categories or classified as
either protein coding or noncoding. If you're
having any trouble with these concepts. Check out the forums and see what some
of your classmates have to say. If I notice there's a lot of
trouble, I'll try to post some clarifying
information there or in the instructor's notes.